To download the data that we'll
be working with in this video,
click on the hyperlink given
in the text above this video.
Don't use Internet Explorer.
Chrome, Safari, or Firefox
should all work fine.
After you click
on the hyperlink,
it will take you to a
page that looks like this.
Go ahead and copy all
the text on this page
by first selecting all of it and
then hitting Control C on a PC
or Command C on a Mac.
Then go to a simple
text editor, like
Notepad on a PC or
Text Edit on a Mac,
and paste what you just
copied into the text editor
with Control V on a PC
or Command V on a Mac.
Then go ahead and save this
file as the name movielens.txt,
for text.
Save this somewhere that you can
easily navigate to in R. Now,
let's switch to R
and load our data.
First, in your R console,
navigate to the directory
where you just saved that file.
And click OK.
Now, to load our data, we'll
be using a slightly different
command this time.
Our data is not a CSV file.
It's a text file,
where the entries
are separated by a vertical bar.
So we'll call it
data set movies,
and then we'll use the
read.table function, where
the first argument is the name
of our data set in quotes.
The second argument
is header=FALSE.
This is because our
data doesn't have
a header or a variable name row.
And then the next
argument is sep="|" ,
which can be found above the
Enter key on your keyboard.
We need one more argument,
which is quote="(backslash)" ".
Close the parentheses,
and hit Enter.
That last argument just
make sure that our text
was read in properly.
Let's take a look at the
structure of our data
using the str function.
We have 1,682 observations
of 24 different variables.
Since our variables didn't have
names, header equaled false,
R just labeled them with
V1, V2, V3, et cetera.
But from the Movie
Lens documentation,
we know what these
variables are.
So we'll go ahead and add in
the column names ourselves.
To do this, start by typing
colnames, for column names,
and then in parentheses,
the name of our data
set, movies, and then
equals, and we'll
use the c function,
where we're going
to list all of the
variable names,
each of them in double quotes
and separated by commas.
So first, we have "ID", the
ID of the movie, then "Title",
"ReleaseDate",
"VideoReleaseDate", "IMDB",
"Unknown"-- this is
the unknown genre--
and then our 18 other genres--
"Action", "Adventure",
"Animation", "Children's,
"Comedy", "Crime",
"Documentary", "Drama",
"Fantasy", "FilmNoir",
"Horror", "Musical", "Mystery",
"Romance", "SciFi", "Thriller",
"War", and "Western".
Go
ahead and close the
parentheses, and hit Enter.
Let's see what our
data looks like now
using the str function again.
We can see that we have the
same number of observations
and the same number of
variables, but each of them
now has the name
that we just gave.
We won't be using the ID,
release date, video release
data, or IMDB variables.
So let's go ahead
and remove them.
To do this, we type the name
of our data set-- movies$--
the name of the variable
we want to remove,
and then just say =NULL,
in capital letters.
This would just remove the
variable from our data set.
Let's repeat this with
release date, video release
date, and IMDB.
And there are a few duplicate
entries in our data set,
so we'll go ahead and remove
them with the unique function.
So just type the
name of our data
set, movies = unique(movies).
Let's take a look at
our data one more time.
Now, we have 1,664 observations,
a few less than before,
and 20 variables-- the title
of the movie, the unknown genre
label, and then the
18 other genre labels.
In this video, we've
seen one example
of how to prepare data
taken from the internet
to work with it in R.
In the next video,
we'll use this data
set to cluster our movies
using hierarchical clustering.